c'est surtout très sincèrement je ne
comprends pas l'intérêt ça n'avait
jamais posé problème jusqu'à présent est
brusquement vie faut mettre du voile
dans le sport je ne comprends pas c'est
tout juste que je ne comprends pas
maintenant c'est à chacun un verre
justement c'est que ça jamais été
interdit donc pourquoi maintenant
devrait l'interdire et pourquoi plus
droit au torino sera ne m'étais pas dit
c'est pas du tout court se vend c'est
juste que qu'on le veuille ou non les
femmes musulmanes on leur a reproché
pendant beaucoup d'années le repli
communautaire de ne pas s'investir dans
la société matin elles en font partie ll
faut du sport elles sont là elles sont
visibles et ça dérange on veut changer
le droit
d'exemption bien sûr mes droits ne l'a
jamais interdit le droit d'autoriser mal
n'était pas visible au sein de ces
compétitions justement qui n'a voulu
légiférer dès mai madjid qu'on vous
entende et livia pourquoi vous êtes
contre vous le voile dans le sport aura
été si on a ce débat en france et pas
dans des pays aux anglo saxons
communautariser c'est parce qu en fait
y'a pas un problème spécifique je pense
en france e d'incompatibilité entre le
voile est la laïcité mais surtout s'il
ya un problème culturel en réalité que
les gens ne veulent pas forcément avoué
ces dernières années on a eu des débats
sur le voile à l'école le voile en
entreprise maintenant le voile dans le
monde du sport est en réalité quand on
croise une petite fille de moins de 10
ans dans la rue personne ne se dit oh
c'est choquant c'est incompatible avec
la laïcité le réflexe est de se dire ce
vêtement est discriminant envers les
femmes puisque effectivement c'est
uniquement les femmes musulmanes qui le
porte et pas les hommes ce vêtement est
une culpabilisation de leur chevelure
dans l'espace public et de leurs
rapports de séduction avec les hommes
puisque effectivement s'il y avait les
hommes et les femmes musulmans et
musulmanes qui portait le voile peut
être sûrs et passé débat là mais le fait
que ce soit un vêtement spécifiques aux
femmes qui cachent leur chevelure pour
cacher ben entre autres leur beauté même
si j'imagine que madame va va sûrement
dire que l est libre de le porter que
c'est son libre choix c'est peut-être un
storytelling très récent j'ai
l'impression moralité il ya une
obligation théologique et religieuses et
je pense qu'elle le sait est aussi en
réalité une liberté c'est aussi le droit
de refuser cette liberté justin est un
petit argument moi par exemple j'aime la
mousse au chocolat gens mangent tous les
jours je peux être libre potentiellement
de ne pas manger un jour si je veux
tandis que l à chaque fois qu'elle met
un pied à l'extérieur de chez elle je
suppose qu'elle doit porter le voile à
chaque fois quand il fait 40 degrés 2
elle doit porter le voile donc ce
systématisme codifié ne me semble pas
être une liberté voilà comme le fait de
manger sur le domaine privé porté sur le
tiramisu
je mange et je me suis dit
qu'elle doit le porter à chaque fois
qu'elle sort deux ans on parlera d'îles
flottantes dans un instant oui pourquoi
pourquoi ça n'existait pas avant et
pourquoi ça existe aujourd'hui parce que
les mentalités elle changer les
mentalités elle bouge et on est tourné
là tout le temps en train de dire on
entend des discours oui alors on l'a
obligé à mettre le voile pour caresser
elle pour qu'elle fasse la cuisine et
qui sortent pas et là quand on a une
preuve d'émancipation justement fallait
se mélanger avec les autres et à les
faire du sport ce qui prouve que ces
discours prouve qu'elle est libre
puisqu'elle va les jouer au foot doivent
d'ailleurs maric et dictateurs qui va
dire va jouer au foot non ça n'existe
pas donc si elle met son voile à jouer
mais non mais si elle met son voile
comme ça et qui avait joué au foot moi
ça me dérange pas et au contraire c'est
une avancée ce qui me dérangerait c'est
qu'on dise maintenant tout le monde mais
le voile mais si elle joue au foot mix
avec dévoiler des noms voile et ça me
dérange pas si elle dit c'est lors d'une
audition d'accord mais je vous dit on
pas là la pole et les gens à calais ce
concert veut jouer au foot et qu'elle a
envie d'avoir chaud plus que les autres
cas veut garder son voile parce que ça
sa religion bah c'est très bien c'est le
jeu bas qu'on interdise par contre qu'on
dise tout le monde mais le voile a bâti
c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose a été arrêté alors lydia moi je
vais gérer mais ce que je suis pas ici
pour lui parler en tant que musulmane
face à d'anciens musulmans parce que ça
m'intéresse absolument pas vous êtes
libre de faire ce que vous voulez
arrêter vous aussi arrêté tout ça et
mais je suis là deux françaises qui
s'écrit face à un français est notre
point commun est ce qui régit notre
société c'est le droit et le droit donne
la liberté de se vêtir comme on le
souhaite et vous en faites vous en
faites vous êtes beaucoup dans
l'idéologie alors que moi je suis dans
le droit et c'est là la différence et
vous voulez vendre quelque chose et moi
absolument pas si c'est le droit
français qui nous régit tous tous ceux
qui nous regardent et tous ceux qui sont
ici présents et en fait je vois
absolument pas où est le débat je
comprends que ça vous dérange le voile
je l'entends mais je ne vous demande pas
de le comprendre mais de le respecter et
c'est ça que toutes les femmes qui
portent le voile à leur demande
aujourd'hui c'est tu ne le respectent et
ne comprenait pas grand bien vous fasse
je comprends votre point de vue je vais
même aller un peu dans votre sang jeu
avant que par exemple en france que je
comprends pour vous que disons un
taliban en afghanistan qui veut obliger
une femme à porter le voile ce soit
pareil qu'en france un homme qui veut
mettre le voilà une femme parce que vous
avez sans doute me dire mais vous êtes
les mêmes dans les deux sens vous voulez
dicter aux femmes musulmanes ce qu'elles
doivent porter ou ne pas porter je
comprends très bien ce débat d'un point
de vue juridique et je sais aussi que si
demain on interdisait aux femmes
musulmanes de porter le voile en france
par exemple elles seraient malina
portrait un bonnet vert tout un bonnet
vert c'est très rare la couleur verte du
coup on pourrait pas leur interdire de
porter un bonnet si on leur interdit
porter un bonnet du coup toutes les
femmes françaises ce que veut dire ce
qu'elles peuvent le contourner facile
sénégalais veulent attaquer mm la beauce
et chocolat ont conservé la maman vous
parlez l'abri dès que je comprends bien
moi je parle culturel voilà
effectivement c'est je pense c'est un
tabou il faut il faut ce défaut qu'alizé
de légers gains de la veille tabouis
faut normaliser cet ordre des choses de
voir des femmes qui portent le voile et
justement c'est très intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que en général j'ai
remarqué une chose c'est que la plupart
des gens qui s'expriment dans les médias
pour défendre l'islam et le voile et par
mme al islam et le belge et défendre le
droit fera alors d'accord mais ne
répondent jamais une question très
simple par exemple c est ce que vous
êtes favorable ou défavorable au fait
que des mineurs de moins de 18 ans porte
le voile on va voir image favorable j'ai
parlé ici j'étais moi-même feist et il y
en a parlé la dernière intervention
jusqu'à quel âge du coup 87 ans s'est
pas construit à partir de quel âge
mineur une mineure de même à 8 ans à 7
ans il peut porter un voile est ce que
je peux répondre à votre argument vous
mais ce cas là la réaction
c'est toujours ça je le répète
l'existant mais je vais répondre alors
moi je ne suis pas là pour auditer
juridiquement il ya un qui leur interdit
avant donc je sais pas là pour dire pour
ou contre 7 ans 8 ans 9 ans et pas c'est
pas le permis de conduire c'est pas tout
c'est juste ça ça c'est 2 1 et 2 2 il ya
quelque chose qui est vraiment qu'ils
ont vraiment à m'agacer c'est que
lorsque je suis sur un plateau je dois
justifier de choses qui ne me concernent
absolument pas moi j'ai porté à 13 ans
j'ai eu l'intelligence le cerveau et
j'ai eu la réflexion et j'ai décidé de
porter si j'avais décidé à 18 ans que
c'était une mauvaise touche colorée
retirer ya personne qui me retient et
surtout les habitants de la planète
terre c'est toujours parmi les 1
milliard 800 millions de musulmans que
des femmes envie de porter le voile et à
avoir un systématisme comme je voulais
10 de jeu mais un orteil dehors je porte
un voile je trouve que cette liberté
pour moi elle m'a l'air bien orienté
culturellement je pense que vous êtes un
peu plus endoctrinés culturellement que
vous le vouliez forcément il ya eu une
influence la preuve les françaises non
musulmane contrairement française
musulmane en général ne porte pas de
voile c'est donc qu'il ya aussi mais les
françaises non musulmane ne voit pas du
tout le débat ils ne comprennent pas
qu'il est méchant raconte beaucoup dans
la rue au rallye c'est parce que tout ne
va pas s'exprimer comme il suit les
débats c'est le voile dans ce port géré
a fait
fort exactement bravo heureusement que
tu es là position bref était
déjà je salue ma future console
r déjà je voudrais dire que
bon on ne va pas terminer en fait avec
le principe de laïcité on pensait que ce
serait réglé avec la loi de 1905 en
réalité ça a créé de nouveaux débats il
faut rappeler que le principe de laïcité
c'est pas le principe de ne pas croire
ou de croire ou de ne pas croire c'est
de ne pas c'est avoir son opinion et le
conseil d'état a rappelé dans un avis
qu'on peut parfaitement porter une tenue
des signes appartement où il n'y a pas
trop élitisme et à partir du moment que
ça ne porte pas atteinte à l'ordre
public donc à partir du moment où des
jeunes filles portent le voile dans les
compétions sportives et que ça ne porte
pas atteinte à l'ordre public et 7 je
sais que c'est très drôle mais c'est
crémont comprend pas du tout ce que vous
dites les regarder il reprend à voir ils
savent à l attentisme ou d'un ton appris
trop dans la gueule
là ils étaient là et voilà près tous les
côtés
je vois bien ce que dit raymond raymond
a tout à fait raison à ce moment où il
n'y a pas de trouver à l'ordre public
n'y a pas de problème alors bien sûr le
droit l'a rappelé s'est dit dans la loi
c-10 également par le conseil d'état
dans ses avis à partir du moment où il
n'y a pas on peut porter une tenue
laisser ce cas très justement dit ma
future console on peut porter une tenue
appartement où il n'ya pas de
prosélytisme
il n'y a pas de risque d'atteinte à
l'ordre public c'est très bien prendre
le rappeler parce que c'est la série 3 2
minutes sur ce sujet vraiment donc une
minute trente sur vraiment les gens
intéressants on aura alors remis police
alesi langil
c'est gratuit moi je trouve que c'est
super intéressant entendez ont dit oui
non non non il faut que le plus
intéressant ce2 quoi et je trouve que ce
qui est bien mais alors barré ou secte
avaient des musulmans ou des gens qui
sont culture musulmane compris athées
etc qui se passe avec dignité et respect
c'est ça le cas ce soir du président et
que ça change parce qu'on sait nous les
français aux non musulmans non musulmans
une opinion et on écoute et on a la vie
oui on n'a pas besoin d'être musulmans
pour avoir un avis sur la question bien
sûr mais c'est bien aussi sur la vie sur
la mousse au chocolat je les dis je
pense que le vrai tabou et d'un point de
vue culturel et pas forcément mon cadre
ai parlé je vous donne un exemple si un
homme se met torse nu ici n'y aura pas
une mention au moins deux saisons ce
sera pas considéré comme érotique mais
ça dépend là un exemple si bien comme
les routes en amont qui a dépassé 1 mais
qui se met au torse nu avec abu défaire
en train de manger de la mousse chocolat
ici
peut-être trop long alors alors c'est
trop long non alors pas de questions on
n'est pas là dedans hockey balle utah
question on évoquerait cette mesure est
temps d'y répondre en démocratie
normalement on respecte les lois wiimote
donc pour l'instant moi je suis
favorable à ce qu'on a le droit et c'est
très bien en plus le sport c'est
l'ascenseur social c'est l'émancipation
donc oui à fond mais imaginons que la
loi ne soit pas votée et que les jeunes
filles qui veulent faire du sport n'est
plus le droit de mettre le voile oui
alors elles vont faire quoi est-ce
qu'elles vont continuer à faire du spam
à la vous vous doutez bien que
ça veut dire que les lois de la
république sont en dessous ti ou
au-dessus priver l'adversaire ça dégage
est la question
c'est dit c'est fait quatre pattes
audition n'a pas encore posé du coup
c'est la vraie saveur parce que pour moi
la loi de la république sont toujours au
dessus des pressions dans ce sport c'est
pas une oie à faire du sport non mais
surtout ça dont je sais c'est un aveu
106 est une tare ni par les sucettes à
l'avenir on va répondre tout simplement
on est d'accord que par exemple un
enseignant dans une école n'a pas droit
de porter le voile est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu une enseignante porter le voile
dans une école non alors à quel moment
les musulmans se sont affranchis de la
ve république jamais cet enfant de la
télé chaîne filles auront dix ans le
voile en aidant les jeunes filles feront
le choix soit de ne plus pratiquer leur
sport vous soit de le faire est de
briser la norme est bien d'accord qu'on
est dans une mixité la très belle angèle
qui ne pratiquent plus l'ambiance sera
vraiment là ça veut dire qu'elle
considère que les lois de la république
sont non pas du tout puisqu'elle s'y
plie absolument pas non mais ce prix le
10 sport vous aimez ça c'est un joint ah
ouais c'est ça c'est leur choix
personnel et la république en y
réfléchissant c'est c'est pour ça qu'il
ya une assemblée nationale c'est pour ça
qu'avec senna c'est pour ça que les
toits tirent il ya plusieurs éditions il
ya des réformes législatives quasiment
pas ces années c'est ainsi